we're looking at the most disappointing
NFL team of the season who has been the
most disappointing team of 2018 Falcons
Giants Jaguars Packers Raiders man the
fact that the Packers are in the mix
with teams and have three and two wins
just says it all and former Green Bay
Packer ten years in the National
Football League you want a championship
with them two-time Pro Bowler now with
Fox Sports Greg Jennings here on the
show how are you Greg what are you
laughing about is that the Michigan
thing - Greg you want to do you want to
chime in there - I've had my suit I go
to Michigan but I'm damn good I know
that and I'm talking you talk about
there's not too many games that will put
a complete damper on your day that I'm
watching I'm a sports guy but that's a
game for the last forever I just had
thank you I appreciate it Greg if you
and my I think your phone's up against
your chin of your cheek or whatever as
we have a conversation with you here on
the program I appreciate the
commiseration there I really really do
let's move on to the Packers then I
guess I you know you had a great segment
here in studio you're kind of my Packers
whisperer to turn to right now I mean
what when you watch a game like last
night there in Minnesota look what is
wrong what is off is there some is it
something you can put your finger on
here Greg it's a it's a couple things
when I watched there there anything
needs to be creative on offense
especially when you're playing a team
that is asking something we on defense
as the Minnesota Vikings that can match
you pretty much therefore banging across
the board and your inability to have
what has always been your lecture in
your corner backing I'm long home from
saying airmobile and being able to make
plays outside the pocket he just has not
been the same this year I think when I
watch the Packers they just they have no
creativity offensively they which I
don't think they have to do as much as
they have they they ride in Rogers from
the start to the finish and they
actually have a decent wedding day which
bin should implement in Jones in that
office I just had wonder but at drawing
from the ball getting him in space I
think that should be one of their secret
guys which they don't really realize him
in my opinion to the best of their
abilities and just simply their
inability to win on the road this is a
young team despite having the Clay
Matthews and the in Rogers and the
loggers and these guys I remember when
we worked together in 2009 I believe it
was and or 2001 of those years and we
just could not win the class games are
our team was young we've had pieces but
we could not win the close games in the
Packers are doing they're doing that
they're able to win the close those per
second we on the road lack of creativity
its offensively they play well and spunk
but it's not sustained it's just a lot
going on in house with the Green Bay
Packers Greg Jennings right here on the
Rich Eisen show so if knowing Aaron
Rodgers as well as you do if he could be
his own offensive coordinator
essentially just run it in the same way
maybe that Peyton Manning used to or
Brady does but even though obviously
plays get called for them if he could be
his own offensive coordinator how
different would this offense look I
think it would look to substantially
different when you look at analyzers
when we see him at his best it is in the
two minute
hurry up style offense
nothing to necessarily have to be hurry
up just two minute no homo in those
situations he is in full control he's in
full control he's calling the place he's
signaling to his guys he's running the
ball he's touring all he's putting him
he's he's actually playing the game the
way he sees it in the way he feels like
he can depict it and he can surgically
just maneuver and just cut through
defenses that way at his optimal best
and that's what I feel at right now they
must go to that allow him to call his
place no huddle get his guys situated
see what the defense is doing
get them off cadence with with his with
his snap con his cadence um let them
show what they're gonna do and what
they're what they're going to as far as
coverages and then wow him so work
that's where he's been on his best Oh
through this clear but specifically now
because there's no creativity if you're
not going to be creative okay let's
let's go what we what we do but let the
guy who can get you in the best
situation do it and right now that's a
rush so what would you say to those who
are somewhat critical of Rogers play
though right now that he doesn't take
the easy throw he doesn't check it down
when it's necessary how do i what do you
say with that okay I agree with that
when when you look at the situations
that he's in most of the time it he
feels as though he has to make that big
throw or that big play which is getting
them in trouble because right now
there's been no game that they has been
that they have just flat-out been out of
are the last their their rope losing
streak right now and when you have an
arm like Aaron Rodgers possesses it is
hard it is almost impossible to not
showcase that arm like you just you want
to you
you don't wanna take the check that one
and become that quarterback but I feel
like in order for them to be successful
with Mike McCarthy calling plays he has
to do those types of things to sustain
drives not throw the ball out of line
and throw it away just take the check
down move the chains
three four yards of pile and and go that
way but if they're if he's unwilling to
do that which he has shown that he's not
willing to do that allowing them to run
the offense that way we can see okay is
it is it or is it there and if it is
last one for you on this subject Craig
Greg Jennings here in the Rich Eisen
show do you agree that the it is time
for the Rogers McCarthy marriage den and
I've been want to say no but the more I
watch them it's like the more it's like
a growing frustration every time they're
unable to come away with a big win which
is every week from here on out they must
win and for when I look at that and I
look at how they they perform on offense
his numbers although they are great when
it comes to looking at them individually
statistically he had he's putting up
great numbers but he also was putting up
some of the poorest members that he's
ever put up and I think that has to be
accredited to number one his health
number two the play calls well I mean
I'm just at least glad for you Greg and
four Packers nation that at least you've
got that ring right I mean but but that
said in in the Rogers McCarthy era just
in terms of that dozen years just having
the the conversation about what other
goat quarterbacks have been in the
league Rodgers in McCarthy kind of lead
the league in needing to run the table
in order to save a season and make the
playoffs and go on a run I mean Brady
did and Brees I'm just going
the Big Ben even maybe Philip Rivers is
the only other one right now that
they've got to go on a run all the time
it just seems that they're always in the
relax or chill out mode or whatever and
so my question for you is that if
McCarthy does go who do you think would
be the right fit for Rodgers as he
approaches his dotage years in his final
window of opportunity to try and bring
another one a title town you know that
that's that's interesting the issue with
a guy like Aaron Rodgers is you have
such a talent and a guy who who really
is stubborn he wants to do it his way
he's kind of bullish if you will but and
so you have to have a coordinator head
coach guy that can challenge his not
only his his intellect but him on the
football field oh and there's not too
many guys out there that can do that but
I feel like he will respect enough like
you know there we were a few weeks ago
talking about the person if they were to
swap like Belichick in Aaron would have
that relationship doesn't have been with
one another would it had been as great
as Tom Brady I'm not so sure I believe
that it would or better but you have to
have a court of coach a head coach that
can come in that has been proven that
they can win that improving that they
have had success offensively and has
almost can be smarter than your
quarterback Dicey's hat is a huge
because era he felt like he's so smart
that he can out think when you think
about them just managing the game he
shells frustration it the way Mike
McCarthy manages the game not just play
calling but just managing the game he
feels like he is smarter than coach
McCarthy in maybe he is I'm not sure and
he knows so much you have to have a guy
that can kind of bottle that and kind of
collect
but at the same time squeeze everything
out of them that you possibly can and I
don't think Mike McCarthy has been able
to do that mask Greg Jennings a poll
question Chris before we send him off
from that post Thanksgiving Monday all
right Greg who's been the most
disappointing team of the season
Falcons Giants Jaguars Packers Raiders
Oh for me it's the Atlanta Falcons I'm
sorry I was gonna say the Atlanta
Falcons but because of all their
injuries idiot the Green Bay Packers
because the expectations that we have of
them every single year is Super Bowl or
bust and this year they may not even
make the playoffs who'd have ever said
that coming into this year that the
Green Bay Packers aren't gonna be in the
playoffs I didn't hear anybody saying
that everybody thought I thought that
they'd win the division
but I also been see the Bears winning
eight of their first 11 - Greg I didn't
see that coming exactly we even heard
where is it not saying that they can't
make a run because we see them do it but
to your point they've had to do this
every single year and I think it's just
too much to overcome this year Greg
appreciate the call always have a great
have a great day and and I know you know
I called you on short notice really
appreciate you answering the bell and
thanks for your sort of bro-hug all the
way from the middle of the great Upper
Midwest for the Michigan loss I
appreciate that have a good one happy
holiday to do - let's chat again soon
that's Greg Jennings man I love chatting
with him the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience